The Joe Rogan Experience there's such an
opening for that because they're the
most interesting athletes because it's
such a difficult thing to do emotionally
psychologically there's so much involved
in it and then when you see behind the
scenes the struggle with weight cut
dealing with injuries dealing with you
know training scenarios and coaching and
all the [ __ ] they have to go through to
get just to get to the cage and have the
cage door shut as a [ __ ] miracle when
you think about what they have to go
through in training I mean everything
you do is designed to break a body and
then you have to practice that so you're
practicing wrestling that breaks bodies
kicking that breaks body punching breaks
bodies elbows knees all that [ __ ] and
then you're scrambling you're always
like in the risk of injury and then
you've got to dehydrate the [ __ ] out of
yourself to make weight
well it's it's what Kamal said on this
podcast it went so viral about it was a
relief
because
every single day he woke up it was
District this Anderson Silva streak it
was this pound pound for pound number
one the champion everybody gunning for
you and I think me being able to talk to
him every day I see the pressures that
he have I see the you know people you
know asking them for money and needing
them for this and need them for that you
know he I I don't know if you want me to
say this but basically he was just like
you know after he lost like even some of
the sponsors are not around no more
which is crazy it's just crazy like
which is crazy he's still the number
four pound-for-pound fighter in the
world he was just dominating the fight
you got head kicked lost in the last
minute and now Fighters is like oh we
got a new Champion let's go over here
all those sponsors can go [ __ ]
themselves if you would drop Kamara
Usman because of one kick knockout in a
sport where that's like dropping LeBron
if someone dunked on him like no it's
over yeah like what are you talking
about like this is what the sport is
that is the consequences and that those
consequences are available even to the
greatest Champions if you get kicked
that's it that's the button you get head
kicked by Leon Edwards that's the button
and everybody would go I would go you
would go you get head kicked that's just
it it was clean there's no surviving
that that's how it is it was that's the
sport it was a like I remember being in
the locker room and I I put my camera
down because I was like shoot shooting
subtle shots at the screen you know you
can't really film the screen like that
the UFC won't let you do that copyright
reasons but just a little bit
I remember it was a minute left I
remember when Herb Dean separated him
with two minutes left I had filmed that
and put it in the video that I put out I
put the camera down I was like finna go
to the bathroom as soon as I put the
camera down I was just looking at the
screen he got head kicked
it was like seeing somebody get shot
like like I I've unfortunately seen
somebody get shot and killed before so
like he had his photographer in there as
well uh his Patty cuts and I turned
around and looked at him
and he was just floored and I was just
like this ain't real like right no I
didn't happen right and I'm sitting
there looking at tomorrow in 10 seconds
later he's moving and I'm like seeing
Leon running around occasion I'm like
did my boys just lose
like he just got knocked out head kicked
cold so you missed the kick itself I saw
it no I put the camera down and you saw
it and I and I was literally about to go
to the bathroom it didn't seem real yeah
I didn't it was it's equivalent like how
numb my body was just like seeing
somebody get shot when Mike Tyson got
knocked out when he fought Buster
Douglas people had the exact same
feeling like there's no way that
happened like you don't believe it
you don't believe it like this is what
always happens Kamara wins he goes in
there he Stomps everybody he wins
yeah I feel like I always said this I I
saw khabib uh two two weeks ago in Dubai
I was in Dubai
and I and I told him I said that's the
only way I saw you or Kamar losing that
was the way khabib was going to lose too
if Kabir would have ever lost he wasn't
getting choked out he wasn't getting
dominated somebody was gonna catch him
and he was gonna be out like that
speaking of Tyson that's why one of my
first memories of fighting like I was
living in Carbondale Illinois and when
that happened I was a kid and I saw
grown men crying in a living room wow
grown man I saw a grown man crying only
other time I saw grown man crying like
that especially black men was when Tupac
died and I was with grown men in the car
and he was listening to all eyes on me
and they were just crying and I was just
like this is crazy like for someone to
have that type of impact on you to where
it's that shocking that somebody could
lose their life but it's also like we
were talking about like anatomy of an
NBA player the consequences of an NBA
player is losing a game the consequences
of losing a fight are so much Graver yes
it's so much different so there's so
much more emotions so much more on the
line if you could you know like you were
with Kamara when he lost yeah you were
in that I mean it's heavy [ __ ] if they
like it
that's what's so passionate about this
if Kamal if this was an NBA game and the
Lakers lost to the Warriors they may be
like are we playing them in a month in
Golden State exactly like tomorrow got
to wait half a year to get that get back
it might be more you never know what if
something comes along with Leon or him
what if someone comes along and they
offer a big fight to Leon that is
exciting and then Leon loses that say
this is my fear a moment after the fight
we at the house so Kamal and Ali go to
the hospital
everybody it's a [ __ ] funeral in this
[ __ ] Mansion we in everybody waiting
on Kamal I'm talking about nobody
talking I'm sitting there packing up
getting ready to leave
Kamal comes in
the [ __ ] is wrong with y'all bro I was
beating his ass like I'm cool like the
[ __ ] like calm down so he like what you
doing like to me he like where the
[ __ ] camera at pull the camera out
I'm like all right yeah he's like
pulling the [ __ ] camera out because
like bro I'm gonna beat his ass when we
fight again I'm cool like hey everybody
you know his mom's side his dad in there
I got all that footage that I'm gonna
use for the like I got some [ __ ] I'm
gonna release that you know I just ended
that film with like see you soon you
know what I'm saying like because it's
like
for me like to see that moment and
capture it and be so close to the guys
powerful I don't think if I was with
LeBron and his 50 managers and it's it's
not the same type of intimate intimate
action no people always ask me like man
you should get a bigger crew and I'm
thinking like
it wouldn't be the same if I had a sound
guy with me in a pi and it and Kamal
just want me and him to be in a [ __ ]
with me truck and just just he talking
to me but he ain't talking to me it's
like you're there with Kamal in a car
that's the same thing with podcasts I
have friends and I go and do their
podcast and they got five people in the
room and do their clipboards and people
shouting out suggestions I'm like bro
you're ruining your own show yeah you're
ruining your own show because you want
it to be big because everybody wants
like a bunch of people there like
working buttons and it looks
professional I'm like you want a
skeleton crew if you're going to have a
conversation you just want two people so
they can connect same thing with you in
a camera when you're in there hanging
with those guys that's our friend will
that's not like some weird guy who who
knows what he's gonna capture be careful
around this dude don't say anything you
know it's that's that's a big part of
what you capture that other people are
not going to be able to get they don't
have your personality that's that's a
factor now it goes a long way goes along
it goes a long way everybody loves you
yeah goes a long way even Dana yeah
[ __ ] yeah well I I think because
I don't ask for [ __ ]